optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and oil is your personal
question now it is
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans Tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times just search Matt
Mullenweg tequila Ferriss for quite an
exciting time whether you're looking to
create a personal blog a business site
or both you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google shall remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box SEO
imaginable end quote and it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30 percent of
the Internet is run on WordPress you do
not need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that they offer 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you to learn more take
a look wordpress.com forward slash tim
for 15% off
an new website check it out this episode
is brought to you by LegalZoom which
more than 2 million Americans have used
to help start their businesses past
guests even such as while WordPress lead
developer CEO of automatic Matt
Mullenweg now valued at more than a
billion dollars have used LegalZoom to
help with their business needs
specifically in his case to form his
company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get a la carte style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show
he's so she booted on there every
episode it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers of different
types and that term world class is going
to come up again in this episode so you
can pay attention to the context and
this particular conversation I have with
me Ann Mira Coe who has been called
quote the most powerful woman in
startups and quote by Forbes and is a
lecturer and entrepreneurship at
Stanford the child of a rocket scientist
at NASA that's a literal rocket
scientist and is a Palo Alto native and
has been steeped in technology startups
since she was a teenager
prior to co-founding floodgate she
worked at Charles River ventures and
McKinsey and company some of her
investments include lyft I as Dee I'm
gonna screw these up I know it Zam Ren
refinery29
joy run TaskRabbit and ModCloth given
the success of her many investments she
was on the 2017 - list of top 100
venture capitalists and I just found out
today back on 2018 elbowing her way to
the top to steal the crown from her
partner Mike maples Jr it's all good
spirited Mike and is known for so many
other things I'm gonna skip some of them
because we're gonna touch on the seeds
of her many many accomplishments in
perhaps some of the first few minutes of
the conversation she has a BSEE
I hope I'm getting that right from Yale
and a PhD from Stanford and math
modeling of computer security she lives
with her husband three kids aged ten
eight and six very well spaced and one
spoiled dog and welcome to the show
thanks for having me so there's so many
places we could start and I was I was
hoping to humanize the ever intimidating
and Mirko which I may only partially
succeed at doing but could we start with
explaining why your brother used to
introduce you or how he used to
introduce you on stage yes so I I had
this brother an older brother by exactly
two years
on the same day and he was one of these
guys who's so confident he knew that he
wanted to study cars and airplanes from
the time that I could I could remember
him existing and and he was always
confident with friends and he was also
confident up on stage and so as any good
Asian child would do we played musical
instruments I played piano he played the
violin and we would always have to
perform and I was painfully painfully
shy and so I would get up on stage and I
would refuse to speak and my mother
knowing this wouldn't let this get in
the way of our performing she would send
my brother up on stage to help announce
whatever I was playing and I have this
real clear memory of being in junior
high and having this happen my brother
got up on stage and said you know this
is Anne Meara she's gonna be playing a
Chopin Nocturne and and go and and I
looked over and I remember thinking to
myself you know like the mental dialogue
that's happening in a teenager's mind
this is totally ridiculous and because
I'm sitting there in front of a room
full of people and I felt fine playing
the piano but I felt petrified speaking
and that's one of like the clearest
memories that I have of my brother and
me and the difference that we had
between the two of us why were you so
shy or nervous about speaking you know
I've always been an introvert so I think
it comes probably directly from that but
I was also sort of I was a strange child
I have to admit I I had a lot of
different interests but I love to do
things by myself and and so I just
didn't I wasn't really that interested
in talking to other people like one of
the the first thing my mom
Ashlee discovered about me when I was a
little kid when I was two I only spoke
Japanese and we were living in Michigan
and I used to be this very hostile
little child and I would walk by anyone
speaking in English and in Japanese I
would say I wish you would leave my poor
mom and so she was like oh we really
should socialize and with people who
speak English and we're living in
Michigan so there's no shortage just hit
pause dude do you still speak Japanese I
do
so I speak Japanese to my parents how do
you say I wish you could I wish you
would leave just for people who want to
mutter that to people in the park or
wherever they might be is do you recall
or how might you have said that as a kid
you have any idea I think I might have
sad let me think about it
that's Justin oh it's got a did the
Hasina that is aggressive that's really
good yeah I think probably more likely
it was Judas I know right oh wow that's
even worse yeah right and so but it was
always like something that like a drunk
dad says yeah yeah it's kind of like
shut up yeah you're really loud you're
really irritating but like like a little
intransigent two-year-old saying that to
a grown-up speaking English in her home
okay I don't want to take us too far off
the rails but we may come back I and
weird yeah and it was one of these
things that I think it really held me
back and I knew I knew actually it was
holding me back this strange part though
was my mom was recently talking to me
about this in a few years prior
to that experience where I'm in junior
high I'm on stage I had actually done
this other thing which was we had this
summer school program where I I would go
to local community college was Foothill
College and all these schools around the
area and when they let out for summer
the students would go to this Community
College take math classes and writing
classes and whatnot so a lot of
elementary school students to high
school students would be at Foothill
College and and so my mom said you have
to pick two classes and one class was a
math class obviously and she said you
could pick your second class and my
brother picked a a normal junior high
school writing class and I was in fifth
grade at the time so ten years old and I
picked a negotiations class and and it
was not in the summer school program it
was an adult class why did you pick that
and I picked it because I remember the
book was getting to yes looked at me and
she said why did you pick this class and
I said it's because they're teaching you
how to get to yeah I want to know how to
get to yes and I have this incredible
experience this caught this community
college of having a class with I imagine
they were pry 30 to 50 year old adults
taking this class and they were probably
the most patient wonderful people and
you know we had this this experience
where you had certain supplies that you
were given on pieces of paper and then
you had to negotiate you're on Mars and
you had to negotiate supply lines and
whatnot and create a real society and in
the simulation they're taking seriously
a ten-year-old kid who's negotiating for
supplies and I I remember taking that
experience and feeling like you know I
was taken seriously and
environment but it was a great
experience because it was a small
classes like 20 people and in that
setting I felt okay
speaking up but then on stage I didn't
still and and so it was sort of these
small steps that felt like I was getting
closer and closer to realizing oh I need
to actually be able to speak up I need
to be able to say things in front of a
large audience and so there was this
desire to face my fears said what was
the next step after that how did you go
about facing the fear of speaking on
stage so in in high school I get to high
school and as every high school freshman
is doing they're looking for different
activities to to participate in and I
decided to dive into Speech and Debate
and speech and debate at this time at
Palo Alto High School was not a very big
activity there were probably about 20
students on the team and I I found that
I really enjoyed it and it was a really
great group of students and then not
only from Powell to high school but from
the local community and I just fell in
love with the idea that you could really
seriously get up in front of an audience
and and talk about really important
issues even as a high school student and
so I dove into that activity and it was
frankly terrible at it
I think freshman sophomore year I didn't
win any tournaments didn't even come
close and that was that was sort of the
way though I decided I could face that
fear what did you what kept you going I
mean there's the the answer that or
perhaps potential answer you gave just a
moment ago which is you really enjoyed
it and you loved it but what did you
love about it what what did you enjoy so
much they were able to persist through
failures over those first two years you
know the first thing is just the people
yeah I reflect actually on the P
that I met in speech and debate and
they're doing incredible things we have
just in my my year alone not in my team
but in my local community professors you
know ones at Harvard and government ones
in philosophy University of Colorado one
woman is now on on the the morning show
on NPR
we have several venture capitalists it
was just a really interesting group of
people all in all in the same age group
who wanted to talk about really
interesting things I also found that the
actual activity itself was something it
challenged me in a way that I hadn't
been challenged before so I was really
good at math and science and those
things really came naturally to me but
getting up on stage and speaking was not
something that was natural to me
but the piece that I did love that came
very naturally was competition and I'm
I've always been this way no I'm just
chuckling because the AK and I have to
cure that right I love I love
competition you you put in points on
anything and I want more I wanted I want
more than the next person and and I
remember the coaches that we had we we
didn't have teachers at our school who
were able to coach and so we had to go
across the street to Stanford and find
students who were willing to coach and
these these kids were you know 18 to 21
years old so they would pump us up by
saying hey if you can get someone to cry
in cross-examination
I'll buy you a slice of pizza and so you
know things like that we're
extraordinarily motivating like you know
logic
and arguments could get you a step
further it was just something that even
though I wasn't good at it at the time I
just loved it and I felt like if I could
just do one more tournament I'd become
even better at it and and you would see
that right and so that that's the thing
that I loved so do you have any memory
this seems like a very very specific
example that you gave the crying in the
pizza did that actually happen did you
succeed at making someone cry and
cross-examination for a slice of pizza
or is that just something I feel like
I'm not succeeding in my desire to
humanize me and make myself seem like a
less of a dragon lady but we'll get
there we'll get there but this is I want
to hear I want to hear this story
several stories so there were points in
time or I remember people would cry in
that they would crumble in the middle of
cross-examination and run out of the
room crying and my coach would see that
and proudly bring me a slice of pizza
after this happened multiple times this
wasn't a single tournament it was and
and there were moments where I got they
had courtesy points to so it wasn't just
about winning it was also whether you
were courteous during that and there
were there were rounds where I got zero
courtesy points and and my coaches you
know they would say they would ask why
we got zero courtesy points just to
really understand if we were just being
mean but a lot of times it was just
because we were you know and I was
particularly tenacious in
cross-examination and and even at the
point where I had the person stumped I
would just keep going I would keep going
keep going at it and so it was I
remember at least you know four or five
occasions where where someone cried and
and left the room before the round was
over so this this was like the Cobra Kai
of debating
bad team from the Karate Kid and it's my
six-year-old at one point right before
kindergarten said hey mama
I could make people cry just with my
words that's it was like a really proud
moment for me and then I had to I had to
course-correct and and and talk to him
about that but no for someone who was is
wondering what I omitted from the bio
that I had in front of me you had two
years of not doing well and then in the
bio we have she placed first in the
National Tournament of Champions and
second in the state of California in
high school and it goes on I'll mention
one more thing it was part of a five
person team at Yale that competed in the
RoboCup competition in Paris France all
right but let's focus on the debating so
how did you go from sort of miss flub
with not succeeding and debating to
getting good at debating yeah this is
where I think it's the love of the game
has to were your parents supportive
through all of these these early trials
and tribulations no so you have to you
have to remember you know I come from
very traditional Japanese parents who
really want me to get into a great
university and my mom at one point right
after sophomore year looks at my record
and my parents were incredibly
supportive they would go and judge these
tournaments every single weekend spend
so much time doing and driving us all
over the state and and my my parents
pulled me aside and said you know this
isn't working you have a losing record
in this activity that you're doing and
you appear to be doubling down on your
time with respect to this and if you
want to get into a good college you have
to you have to perform well in whatever
you're doing you know just it's not just
about effort you have to have results
and I remember my mom said to me I've
heard fencing is a great way to get into
an Ivy
remember looking at her and I was like
how how is it possible that she's my
mother she clearly does not know
anything about my athletic abilities if
she's suggesting that I move into
fencing at this moment and so I said to
them point taken
give me the summer and I'm going to to
just work on it I'm gonna and this was
back before the Internet so I working on
it meant I was at Stanford green library
reading philosophy books and reading
articles about the I think they had 12
topics twelve possible topics that
they're going to pull from for the next
year and I just studied those topics I
lived in the library and then I emerged
that year to start competing and when
they announced that first topic I knew
that topic cold and then I could write
my cases really quickly I had already
done all this research and I remember
going into my very very first round and
and had this deal with my parents if I
didn't win one of my first two
tournaments or at least place then I
would quit and I had this distinct
impression walking into my very first
round of debate that fall and feeling as
I looked across at my opponent that
there was no way that they could have
out prepared me and so I knew that
whatever they they said I would have
five arguments against and it was this
incredible knowledge that that it's not
that you can be lucky and turn your luck
around you actually make your own luck
and for me that was a profound lesson
because
I placed in that tournament and I placed
in the next tournament and it was like
that it just never stopped after that
and I had a losing record all through my
freshman sophomore year and it's like I
turned it around junior year
very suddenly and the main difference
was that I was willing to outwork and
outdo every competitor who walked in
through that door for people who don't
know the format and I'll be honest I've
been surrounded by enough surrounded by
but certainly in the same universities
and so on where debate teams existed but
I've never seen a debate competition
what what is what is the format so it's
it's a bunch of nerdy kids dressed in
suits holding briefcases and then maybe
that's changed but that's what it was
back then and then you have a resolution
that's been announced nationwide and
that resolution is generally has some
philosophical elements to this is also
lincoln-douglas style of debate and you
have what does that mean if you don't
mind so so it's one person against one
person so it's individual and it's
value-based and so you're really
debating philosophy so an example of one
debate that we did the principle of
majority rule ought to be valued above
the principle of minority rights or
resolved that education is a privilege
and not a right so so all of these
debates are really surrounding not a
specific policy but it has some
application in the real world and what
you're trying to debate is a
philosophical underpinning behind that
statement and what I loved about debate
was you are actually forced to debate
both sides so you had to have cases
ready for both the affirmative and the
negative so Pro the resolution and
against the resolution
and the format is the affirmative goes
up and talks about this resolution and
says all the reasons that that they
support it and then there's a short
cross-examination where the negative
then cross-examines the affirmative asks
questions of the affirmative then the
negative gets up and talks about all the
reasons that they're against the
resolution and then goes point by point
against all of the arguments that the
affirmative made and talks about why
they're wrong and then there's another
cross-examination of the firm ative
against the negative and then the
affirmative gets up for rebuttal
negative gets up for a rebuttal and then
the affirmative does closing arguments
well it's sort of shorter and shorter
speeches towards the end and how is the
outcome determined what are the the
parameters yes oh so it really depends
on the turn aside from aside from
courtesy courtesy points it's all about
courtesy there's two different types of
tournaments actually when I was debating
one was where you had parent judges and
that I would say really the the style of
speaking your flair really would come
into play your sense of humor
it wasn't really just a line by line
arguments there was also places where
you would go where college students were
the judges or experienced coaches were
the judges and that's where really the
line by line logic becomes much more
important than just the style of your
debate so it really depends on your
audience and you had to read the
audience correctly and did they just
then say I
I choose a or b or do they have to rank
like the sort of Olympic style one to
ten in some fashion so you only have two
debaters that you're you're judging and
you vote for one of them and and in some
of the rounds you have just a single
judge
then in another and in the the breakout
rounds that semi-finals you you might
have a panel of judges and they can't
confer they're just sort of voting
individually on who wins see you you may
be at a point now with debate and
argument that you've reached these the
unconscious competency phase in the
sense that in skill acquisition one
framework that the one could use to
think about skill acquisition as you go
from unconscious incompetence to
conscious incompetence to conscious
competence than unconscious competence I
don't know if this question is going to
be a good one but I'll try it anyway for
people who want to get better at
debating and structuring arguments and
so on are there any books or approaches
or resources anything exercises that you
would suggest well getting to yes mm-hmm
I thought was always really good I
actually found the philosophical texts
to be extraordinarily informative so
anything where you have that Socratic
method in a book I found really a great
way of learning how people debate the
greatest philosophers Aristotle and
Socrates even you know when you get into
more modern literature around justice
you have people like John Rawls writing
that is actually a dialogue and a real
logical debate and I always found those
examples to be really great to read how
people argue philosophical constructs
you know presidential debates to be
honest in politics aren't real debates
because it's two ships passing in the
night
and you don't have real conflict between
people I've also found like the British
parliamentary system if you've ever had
the chance to see that on I think
sometimes it's on c-span
that's actually an interesting
observation of a real-world debate as
well because they will actually engage
in dialogue around policy and it's not
just ad hominem attacks though I find
those sort of real-world examples much
more powerful than someone going sort of
point by point in teaching you how to
debate it because I think that how is
much more around how do you engage in
the idea how do you read and research
both sides of an argument and what do
you believe on both sides and so you
know one way to do that would actually
take a fairly controversial topic and
then actually read read a lot of
literature on both sides of the argument
and then understand where actually the
conflict happens you know are there
definitions that people don't agree on
are there are there nuances that that
people haven't thought about are they
are they real is there real conflict or
are they two ships passing in the night
I think you could do that with even the
gun control debate or you could do that
with immigration or you could do that
with abortion and really understand both
sides of an argument and that that's
that's the way to engage in the process
of debate I believe and if we're if
we're reflecting back on your Cobra Kai
training four slices of pizza I'd be
really curious to know if there are any
particular approaches or questions or
play books that you find very useful in
a heated argument and I'll give you some
hypotheticals right look let's say that
you are on stage at an event and you are
doing a Q&A of the audience and you have
someone who ends up being really hostile
or attacks you or it could be on someone
on stage you're just having a
contentious debate of some time I find
it fascinating to see how people even
with no real logical advantage shut down
opponents and I'm not saying that's
you in this case but for instance
whatever people may think of our of our
dear current President of the United
States I do find it fascinating how
effective he has been at saying check
your facts right and and it just throws
enough imbalance into the dynamic where
someone's like wait a second maybe I did
miss one piece of due diligence that
they're on their heels and it opens up a
window and creates sort of a an illusion
of them being stymied that is really
advantageous I'm like wow I mean it's
it's kind of gross on one level but it's
also kind of brilliant yeah and I also
have a lot of lawyers in my family and
so one thing that they'll do not to say
they all love arguing but a lot of them
do and you'll you'll say something and
they will go so let me just get this
straight here so I understand you're
you're saying that X and they'll kind of
take your argument and like inch they'll
inch it a little closer to absurdity but
just subtly enough that you'll say yeah
that's about right and they'll say okay
so really what you mean is X right and
they start to edge you over before they
even counter with an argument to make
you contradict yourself or kind of seem
ridiculous and then it's they just have
to kind of finish you off but I've never
taken never taken debate and but I do
find this really practical and and
really interesting so it's a long way of
enjoying but yeah like what are you what
are your thoughts on any of that so it's
funny my husband has said to me in the
past and this is a lesson that I
continue to try to learn and relearn is
that life is not a debate and and you
know what he's saying it's funny he was
a debater as well in college and in high
school and we joked that I would still
have beaten him in high school if we had
actually gone head-to-head but but I
think it's a really important point that
life isn't about winning the argument
and
and he's also said to me in the past you
know it's not it's not about being right
and I think that's so true and it's
something that I'm always trying to
really practice in life and I think it's
the debater and me makes it really hard
the the things that you're pointing out
are what's important about it is that
people have a tendency to have an inner
dialogue where they're there right and
instead of really listening to the other
person they're coming up with a next
argument that proves that person wrong
and so so if you go back to what I
really loved about debate and what I
felt like I got out of it it was
actually this ability to see both sides
of an argument to really delve into a
topic and understand why the the side
that I actually naturally believed could
actually be flipped on its head and and
that was a really important skill to
develop and I think that was so much
more important to develop then the skill
to argue for my side because I think in
the world today what we don't see enough
of is empathy for people you might even
disagree with and we get stuck in our
version of truth and what is right and
we aren't truth seekers anymore as a
result we're truth winners true yeah
very true and that that's a piece that
really makes me sad is that you know
when people are like oh this debate
skill is so great to have because now
you can like Ram people with your ideas
and and I've never seen a situation
where you shouted people down and
convinced them you were right and I've
seen situations where by developing true
empathy for the other side you actually
create bridges and you create
commonality and you
create situations where you can actually
work together and and I think that's the
piece I would take away from my debate
experience I would say actually making
the person cry and cross-examination
probably is not the skill that I should
be using in real life although maybe
sometimes I do just when you're teaching
your yours your son the blackmagic I
should point out just so people don't
think I'm completely sort of drinking
the kool-aid of the bloodlust of this of
this potential sport although I do find
it very very fascinating as an insight
into some parts of human nature but the
book you mentioned getting to yes which
is part or a byproduct of the Harvard
negotiation project as I recall yeah is
not a book about proving you're right
it's a book about getting outcomes yes
and there's another book which I believe
was co-authored by one of the co-authors
of getting to yes called getting past no
which I also really really like and it
is about both of these books any book
really on negotiation is about achieving
a very particular outcome or arriving at
a a desired result as opposed to proving
that you're right so I just want to
underscore that because there's a very
real-world difference as you already
noted between say debate and negotiation
I mean the toolkits are very similar
perhaps in some respects but in in
debate you're not gonna have to think
about I wouldn't imagine something like
the Batna that they talked about in
getting to yes you're your best
alternative to negotiated agreement like
like walkaway power or what your options
are you don't necessarily have to go
through that thought process but when
you step into the real world you're not
just trying to prove that you're right
you're trying to get someone to concede
something and agree to a certain set of
terms or a price or whatever it might be
amicably trying to break up with someone
or get together with someone or would
have a divorce or whatever it might be
you're really trying to manifest some
type of outcome or damage control it's
really really different from being a
truth winner and the the world class
term that I mentioned in the intro and I
used a little bit of foreshadowing
saying that I suspected it might come up
a little bit later so I'm doing in doing
homework for this conversation I read
and I don't think this is a misquote but
that your dad even when I think you were
gonna be photocopying in the dean's
office would remind you to be world
class yeah and you would ask you if you
turn in a calculus assignment is that a
world class effort could you talk a
little bit more about this and that's
not that that wasn't my experience
growing up my parents certainly
encouraged me to do a good job but I
tell us a little bit more about your dad
in this particular case and and how that
was used yeah so my my dad grew up in
Tokyo right at the tail end of World War
two and so one of his earliest memories
actually is just planes coming across
Tokyo and the fire bombs and he escaped
to the countryside and and then came
back to Tokyo for high school his father
passed away when he was in college and
he literally tutored kids when one guy
was like the Prime Minister's son until
so that he could make enough cash to
support his family he had three other
siblings and he was one of these
incredible academics and so he was at
the top of his class and
the famous high schools in Tokyo went to
Tokyo University was also then went to
Toshiba which at the time was one of
these great companies to work for and
then he ran into a friend who who told
him he was he was also a friend who was
one of the top at his high school who
said hey there's great opportunities in
America and this this person had gone
off to Princeton and gotten his ph.d and
was at that time working in one of the
the great labs in IBM and was also
becoming a professor and and my dad
decided that he also wanted to go to the
US and he was the eldest son and so
having a mother who's a widow and three
siblings he had to take care of them
until he had saved up enough all of his
siblings were married and his mom had
the courage to say you know what you can
go you can go to the US so this is her
the backdrop for who my dad is he comes
to the United States without speaking
very much English gets a PhD in
mechanical engineering aerospace
engineering and then is in LA ultimately
as a postdoc and an associate professor
my mom comes to marry him and they are
the only family members living in the
United States so really no support so my
dad eventually makes his way out to NASA
at Moffett Field and and my memories of
him he was very engaged on the academics
but he would wake up at 5:00 in the
morning and go to work and he'd bring
back reams of paper and would continue
working late into the night he loved
what he did and so when he turned to me
on anything I ever did from the time I
was a small small child I would be
writing something and if the handwriting
wasn't need enough he would say hey is
this world-class and I remember thinking
to myself
you know for five-year-old the Alice's
world class but he would always push he
would always say is this really you know
the best that a five-year-old could ever
do and it was a constant message and the
the story you're pointing to is one when
I was in in college after living through
a lifetime of this is this world class
question I had a moment where I was
starting my my financial aid package
included you know ten hours of work
study and I had the opportunity to work
in the office of the Dean of engineering
and what was really funny to me at the
time and since I'm leaving to go to my
first day of work
I called my parents and my dad gets on
the phone he said make sure you do a
world-class job and I thought my dad
thought I was like really doing
something important in the office and in
fact I was just photocopying and I said
to my dad I'm photocopying and him
filing there's no such thing as
world-class there and he said well I'd
still think about it and so I get to the
office and I am actually just
photocopying and filing and I remember
standing in front of this photocopy
machine with the stack of papers
thinking to myself what is world-class
in this situation and I decided it was
really crisp copies where you couldn't
tell that it was a photocopy and so I
remember really trying to make you know
the the color match and everything was
straight and I spent a lot of time on
the details and when I was filing things
I didn't just handwrite it I got a label
writer and I'm I made sure it was
printed out on labels and I really tried
to do everything as as well as I
possibly could and I remember I was
getting donuts and I would like make
sure I got the the fresh donuts instead
of the ones that had been standing out
in the basket for a while so every
step of the way it was what can I do to
make this experience for the Dean or for
his executive assistant a delight moment
and it was a real lesson for me because
it was a case of real ownership I felt
so much ownership of the job I was doing
even though from the outside I think
most people would have thought it was
just sort of a grunt job and I think
that's sort of again when I come back -
you don't just get luck you you make you
you create these opportunities for
yourself to me was was a real will real
learning experience right I mean you're
you're you're looking at the potential
precursors of luck and trying to set the
conditions even though they might not
always produce luck the you can increase
the likelihood of it happening which i
think is a perfect segue to discussion
about spring breaks don't worry this
isn't isn't going anywhere
tricky this isn't going anywhere tricky
this relates to shadowing I'll just
that'll be my cue which ya bring you
back so alright we're to lead into this
I you were giving a man a tour around
Yale yeah who is this man why were you
giving him a tour what happened and I
actually don't know all the details I
just I found two lines in a past
interview I was like you know what I
want to dig into this because I don't
there's more to this story I know it
yeah so I'm like I I'm a I'm a junior at
the time at Yale and doing this office
work and the Dean of engineering was
this this this older gentleman Allan
Bromley and he had no idea who I was
I've been working in this office for I
think two years but he barely knew my
name but he was he was just like this
great he'd worked under George
was senior he was he was a legendary
physicist and I really look up to this
man and so one day he he pokes his head
out of the office and the executive
assistant was out and he said who are
you
and I said I'm Anne Meara
I'm your I'm your student assistant in
this office and he said oh I've heard of
you
I need you to go and give this this
friend of mine a tour of the engineering
facilities and he's like I know you'll
do a good job Sarah's told me are great
and so I I take this gentleman and I
take him on a fairly thorough tour of
the engineering facilities and we just
had a great conversation and he it
started off with you know where where
are you from and I said I was from Palo
Alto and it turns out this guy is also
from Palo Alto and we're just sort of
talking about Palo Alto and in the
buildings that are around us and my
growing up back in Palo Alto and in the
middle of it he said hey you know what
are you doing for spring break and it
just so happened I was going to go back
home and visit my family and he said
well that's great because I'm wondering
if you want to come and shadow me and
see what I do for a living and in my
complete self-centered moment of being a
you know junior I hadn't asked this guy
what he did for a living and so I said
well what do you do for a living and he
said I'm the CEO of hewlett-packard I am
such a [ __ ]
and and I said I think that would be
amazing
to be able to shadow you for a couple of
weeks during spring break and so this
man Lew plot invites me to just shadow
him in 1997 and I am going around
literally you know
he didn't have a driver he was this was
really just the Hewlett and Packard era
of CEOs he drove himself around in a
Ford Focus
I remember this we would go to different
meetings and he took me around and one
of the days actually
Bill Gates came to make an announcement
about dot gnat with Hewlett Packard and
so it was an incredible event that
happened I got to sit backstage and see
everything that was happening and LU
plot that invited the photographer to
come in and actually take a picture of
me talking to Lou and I didn't really
think about it but after the fact I get
back to my dorm and Lou Platt has sent
me a thank-you letter saying thanks for
coming to visit I thought you would
enjoy these photographs and there's two
photographs in there I framed them in my
office now one is a picture of me
sitting on it on a seat
talking to Lou and then the second
picture is Bill Gates sitting exactly in
that spot that I was sitting in Hocking
- Lou plot and you know to me like
mentorship means so many different
things I've had so many different
examples of mentors but to a junior in
college who who literally is a nobody he
was such an incredible example of
mentorship he never asked for my resume
he never asked for my GPA he just sort
of took this girl and said you know what
you have you have something and I I see
it and I'm gonna show you something even
greater and to me that is such it was
such a gift it was so incredible because
I hadn't even thought about my own
personal potential ever no one had ever
described anything to me and I came back
from that with my mind completely blown
I met Anne Livermore who is an executive
and I never seen a female executive in
my entire life and here's someone who I
could look at and and see and I can see
that people around her respect her it
was just a it's a it's a life-changing
moment and it comes from that first you
know comment from Dean Bromley who says
I've heard of you I heard you do a great
job and that's where the opportunities
opened up you're the you're the woman
responsible for my fresh doughnuts and
crisp photocopies I've heard good things
now I should know you don't have to go
too deep into this but in a way you were
perfectly primed for doing a good job
with your photocopying and labeling
after spending was at summers in
Kanazawa in the stationery store my
first job was literally helping my my
uncle and grandmother sell office
supplies in Kanazawa Japan at our store
Taiki doll Taiki though and kinda though
it is just such I've never been to
Kanazawa for those people who don't know
I used to live in Japan long time my
first time out of the US was a year in
Japan as an exchange student which is a
whole separate story but never made it
to Kanazawa until a few years ago it's
gorgeous and it's not that far away from
Tokyo at all but such a cute spot with
so much to offer
I'm sorry go ahead yeah it's it's
actually incredible because it's one of
the few cities in Japan that was
protected by historians the u.s. it did
not get bombed in World War two because
of some of the historic elements of the
city so it's almost like a smaller
version of Kyoto and it has a historic
Japanese garden called Kendall Cohen
handling is unbelievable unbelievable so
it's it's like and I summers I would
spend maybe
two blocks away from kenrokuen so it was
an incredible set of summers but yes I I
used to man the cashier register at the
the office supply store so I know my
pens and notebooks and stamps like
nobody's business do you have any
favorite go to what don't worry I'm not
gonna spend too much time on this but do
you have any favorite notebooks or pens
or items of those types that you use
today yeah yeah totally so on pens
I love the juice up Oh for how do you
spell juice it juice up Oh juice up okay
yeah juice up Oh for you can get them on
Amazon they're super thin pens Oh for
the 7.4 millimeter or something yeah
yeah and then four notebooks
it's the noona it's nu UN a some
European brand but but I like any
notebook that has the dot matrix on it
and those the the paper quality is
really great I see dot matrix it's not
it's not that it's not like graph paper
there is there are perpendicular lines
that are dotted yes yes I'm very
particular yeah they go on and on it
appeals to the Dungeons & Dragons nerd
in me anything that resembles a craft
paper so the juice up Oh for and the
nuna yeah definitely anything European
sounding with the repeating vowel I'll
pay 40% more for maybe maybe maybe a
hundred percent maybe other I you
mentioned that you have these
photographs in your office I'm curious
you're sitting in your office right now
yeah alright so what else I'm sure you
have photographs or family but outside
of kind of the usual suspects is there
what are other items that you have in
your office that are important to you
let's see I have the original lift pink
mustache it used to go in the front of
the cars which I love I have also a
picture and a set of laser etched
metal plates that students gave to me
that have sort of a word bath of all of
the words that they thought they could
they ascribed to me yeah students of
what what what was the context of these
students interacting with you and what
are some of the words yeah so I had I
teach at Stanford so after my PhD what I
realized was I loved teaching more than
anything else and so I stayed in contact
with a Tina Seelig and Tom Byers over at
Stanford who run the Stanford Technology
Ventures program and they've given me
the opportunity to teach a few different
classes but the one that I got these
metal plates and the photograph from was
the class of 2013
Mayfield Fellows group and they have
words like Thunder lizard badass
inspiring mother so you know it's just
really fun to see sort of wet words they
thought what were you what were you
teaching these Mayfield Fellows so we
were teaching them basic concepts behind
leadership and entrepreneurship and it's
sort of the first exposure that they got
as juniors and seniors in to really you
know startup ecosystem what does venture
capital do it within that ecosystem what
are the tough choices that you have to
make as a leader within these types of
organizations
what does growth look like in these
types of organizations so it's just sort
of startup 101 but what I love about it
is it's only twelve students and it goes
for nine months Wow so if you get to be
involved in it you get to really know
some of the students and I've been
mentoring students and sometimes
teaching some of these classes since
2008
and you get this whole arc of the career
path of young people and and I really
love it I think it's just sort of you
get to see you know students who start
off as seniors and then they start their
career and they might go to grad school
then they go back and get a job then
they have they get married and then I
think one is now about to have a kid so
you just sort of see this whole arc and
it's just about 10 years 20 years behind
where I was and so I get I get to see
this incredible progress that these
students make over time so it's it's
something that I love and Yuriko mother
of thunderlizards aka mother of dragons
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
we're going to come back to Thunder
lizard because that there's a whole lot
wrapped around that but yeah I'm gonna
try to keep my brain somewhat focused
here he's there a reading list for that
class or do you recall anything that was
on a recommended or required reading
list for that class yeah so we actually
teach a I'm starting a class today at
Stanford for the new spring quarter and
in this class what we're teaching is
what I would call intelligent growth
it's a little bit different than
Mayfield Fellows but my hypothesis my
belief is that just like fake news in
politics there's actually something that
we would call fake growth and leave a
lot of it
we've worshiped at the altar of growth
for about 5 to 10 years now and what
I've seen is that and this is startup
growth specifically specifically within
startups there's so much that we see
that is fake and and no one has
described actual adjectives to growth
until now and so the class that I'm
teaching to engineering students at
is around what is actually intelligent
growth and so you asked about the
reading for it it's all around some of
these case studies that we've seen a
great example of that to me is Qualtrics
we're gonna have Ryan Smith who is the
CEO of Qualtrics come in and speak and I
think he's a great example because I
think he was at 50 million dollars in
revenues before he raised a dime of
venture capital money and so as a result
he's gonna own an incredible piece of
this company when it exits and it will
and so I love the capital efficiency
with which he built his business I also
think you know one of my company is lyft
is a great example of having that kind
of discipline early on and not just not
just wasting venture capital dollars in
the early days when they didn't have
product market fit so they spent
two-and-a-half years working on this
platform called Zimride knowing that
they had to get to density in riders and
Zimride was just it was a platform where
you could find carpooling arrangements
and was being sold to universities and
companies but we couldn't get enough
density to get transactions really
moving fast and it was two-and-a-half
years before they launched lyft and in
the first six weeks you could start to
see that there was a real traction there
and it was only after they they knew
they were doing with lyft that they went
and raised large round with Founders
Fund and then an even larger round with
andreessen horowitz and and that that
story of really really hacking value
before you go out and hack growth is
something that I don't see often enough
in in Silicon Valley so it's something
that I'm I'm continuing to seek and I
love to see companies especially outside
of Silicon Valley that that do that and
that's when we come back to hunting for
thunderlizards that's what I'm looking
for
when you mention the case studies do you
have written case studies that you're
using much like I don't know if Stanford
uses these but much like the Harvard
Business School case studies after these
kind of three-ring binder yeah a 5 to 10
page cases that are published you use
those yeah we use so the ones that we
focused on there's a Harvard Business
case on floodgate that you can purchase
off of the Harvard Business Review
website all right sorry so anyone can
purchase these you don't have to be a
student and I just yeah I don't
interrupt but keep going because the
format of these case studies is really
interesting to me and as an undergrad
senior when I took ed Shouse class in
high tech entrepreneurship which is how
I met Mike maples junior who's going to
be a recurring character shortly
I remember how useful they were so
that's that's the only interjection
sorry to interrupt
no exactly so we we use that case study
for Qualtrics
there's one on floodgate so if you go to
the Harvard Business Review site you can
actually just search for flood gate or
Qualtrics and they'll come up and
they're somewhere between you know five
and $15 they're pretty easy to buy and
download but I think those two in
particular are quite valuable we have
then also just people coming in and
speaking about some of the things that
they've learned and how to grow that
business from 0 to 1 and then 1 to X and
people like Michael Seibel who has now
partnered Y Combinator
but also was part of justin.tv
and Socialcam we have Stephanie Schatz
who was the fearless leader on the sales
side for xamarin she had 18 straight
quarters of beating the stretch target
so you could only imagine how incredible
she is as a Sales Leader taking company
from zero to 50 million dollars in
revenues so we have a lot of different
types of people whether they're CEOs or
CRO s
or venture investors coming in to talk
about the the kinds of trade-offs they
had to make and and how they decipher a
growth to make sure that they're they
have the real kind and not just kind
that they're buying right it just to
elaborate on that for people who may not
be in the startup world if if for
instance you're sitting in on an
incubator investor day and you see 12 12
companies in a row that have 20%
month-on-month growth with very
similar-looking charts there is some
possibility that they have been
inflating or manufacturing their numbers
with paid acquisition to raise funding
or do any number of things and it's
really easy to it's it's relatively easy
to spot once you know the symptoms but
there are an end then there are I
suppose as you know Richard 5-minute
would say the physicists but you must be
sure not to trick yourself or you fool
yourself and you're the easiest person
to fool you can also get very caught up
with what you might consider vanity
metrics but let me take a step back and
just ask well before I ask people
definitely take a look at the case
studies for both Harvard and if you
search Stanford GSB which is the
Business School case studies you'll also
find a website with these profiles of
companies and not just companies but
decisions they had to face generally
where you can determine for yourself
what you would do in a given situation
then read about what they did whether
it's MongoDB I'm looking at this
Stanford GSB site and the case studies
right now so nose and so on how did you
go to investing how did you first be
become exposed to say venture capital
what did you think you're gonna do in
college when you were in college junior
year what do you thought what do you
expect you're gonna do when you grew up
yeah I actually had multiple different
paths so I started off when we were
talking about my brother describing this
kid who knew he wanted to work with cars
or airplanes from the get-go and guess
what he's doing right now he's in
Germany working with racecars so you
know and
was the complete opposite I think when I
was four I wanted to be a farmer then
somewhere along the lines I really
wanted to be a doctor and I wanted to be
a doctor for a fairly long period of
time where in you know freshman year
summer I took organic chemistry it was
in this pre-med track
I think sophomore year summer you take
the MCATs if you're pretty sure you want
to go to medical school and that summer
I was with my best friend who also
really wanted to go to medical school
and she is right now studying leukemia
she's a doctor at UCSF so she's she's
clearly gone down that path and doubled
down on it but I remember going to study
for the MCATs with her and I I turned to
the side and I looked at her and I had
the sudden realization which was that
then this is two days before we're
taking the MCATs
I said hey Kathy I hate hospitals
I don't like actually being around sick
people I also don't love it when people
are always complaining to me and
and I think that might get in the way of
me being a doctor and she looked at me
like I was an alien and she said why are
you saying this right now we're about to
take the MCATs and we need to go study
for it at Kaplan and but you know I was
just constantly observing her and she's
just this incredible human being and she
continues to be but this realization of
wow like the actual job of being a
doctor may not be something that I
actually enjoy was really a hard
realization when you've been all-in for
this long and so but it was it was a
realization that I really had to face
and I knew I knew my gut that I was
doing it because it was a really great
path it was a path where I knew what the
next step was I knew what next class I
had to take I knew the next exam I had
to take then there was
applications then there was school and
then there was residency and fellowship
and it just felt like a really
predictable thing to do but the actual
work at the end of the day was not
something I was going to love or enjoy
and that was really disturbing to me and
so I really screeched off of that path
and I had and it was hard because I had
actually taken all of the requirements
except for biology and the pre-med
requirements did not actually overlap
very much with Electrical Engineering so
I taken a lot of extra classes to make
it a possibility but realized also it
wasn't for me and that's where I was
sort of in this state of not knowing
what I wanted to be and that I paused
for one second yeah so what you just
described illustrates a a degree of
self-awareness but also decision-making
that I think is is rather uncommon in
the sense that I know a lot of people
who have gone on to become doctors or
lawyers or fill in the blank that has a
lot of prerequisite training and
schooling because of say succumbing to
this sunk cost fallacy like oh god I've
put in so much time even though I have
this intuitive feeling I'm not going to
like it I really should do it and what
was the conversation or the background
that allowed you to step off of that
path and not to beat the like Asian kid
drum too hard but but let's be real
right I mean you're also I mean that's
that would be a very admirable well
respected happy to share at a dinner
party with friends type of path for your
parents I would assume all the more
uncommon that you would step off of that
track how is that how is that the case
why why why were you different so I
think it goes back to actually the
moment in debate where I I my mom is
telling me you should you should do
fencing instead of
there was this realization of oh my
parents really love me but they don't
know me and they they don't actually no
one really knows me in terms of my
capabilities and what I feel like I can
get done no one knows that better than I
do and and it was a it was an important
lesson for me because one other fact
that I didn't mention is that in as a
kid there was no sign that I was special
except for you know these weird
characteristics where I would go learn
negotiations but I failed the IQ test
multiple times and the school district
insisted I was not gifted or talented my
mom had to fight for me to be part of
this gifted and talented program as a
two-year-old after I I was really
hostile to people who spoke English
my mom stuck me in tried to put me into
preschool to socialize me but I ended up
biting the person who was interviewing
me poor for a preschool slot and they
put me in special education and and I
was I was one of those kids who got
picked up in a short yellow bus from our
house and taken to a state-run program
for for for special children and and I
think for a long time my mom wasn't
really sure what I was but she just
decided to be all in on the fact that I
was gifted and talented even if I wasn't
and she was really worried that I was I
was one of these special children and
and and so I had sort of an environment
around me way before Yale where I knew
what I was capable of even if the test
scores showed that I wasn't and I knew
that I knew what I was capable of even
if my parents
see it on me and I think there's sort of
this this moment in time that people
need to have where where you realize
that there's no test for human potential
there's no recognition for that it's
something that you have to find inside
of yourself and I think for me you know
that that one of those tests was
actually going back to am I am I gonna
be a great doctor and if I revisit this
question that my dad had always asked me
can you be world-class I knew I couldn't
cuz I looked at Kathy and she was gonna
be world-class because she loved she
loved helping people and she loved
helping people from that kind of
caretaking perspective which was not
where I was gonna be world class but I
felt like there was something in me
where I could be great at something that
just wasn't it mm-hmm and how did you
have that you have all this technical
training by this point me of the
chemistry but you certainly also have
the let's see here
at that point the electrical engineering
probably yeah how does finance and
investing or startups I don't know which
came first enter the picture yes so
having grown up in Palo Alto
I was actually exposed to a lot of
startups as it even as a kid my I used
to babysit for a serial entrepreneur and
he was always tinkering around in his
garage and I remember thinking to myself
oh he he works for himself which is very
very cool I also on my debate team was
Lisa Brennan Jobs who I didn't really
realize she was the daughter of Steve
Jobs until I was in her house and we
were we were talking about debate I was
I was a senior at the time and I was
helping her through learning the the
ropes of Speech and Debate and Steve
Jobs sort of appeared out of nowhere and
I remember thinking to myself what what
is Steve Jobs doing in this house
and so you know it was just sort of it
was all around and and so venture
capital was something that actually a
friend of mine had brought up when I was
still struggling with this notion of
what should I be and he was a real
finance guy and he said you know you're
you're really good at technology and
you're now interested in business
because of this exposure to loop lot you
know have you ever thought of venture
capital and I remember kind of reading
about it and having heard a little bit
about it growing up looking into it and
realizing oh you have like all all this
work experience you need to have I
talked to a couple of former jelly's who
were venture capitalists and and sort of
had that in my in the the back of my
head and so you know I went off to work
at McKinsey as a consultant for three
years and then in in the process of
trying to figure out what to do next
I met venture capitalists by the name of
Ted dinger Smith and in that interview
with him we spoke about not about
technology not about the research I'd
done or my work experience but he wanted
to know what books I was reading he
wanted to know about the music that I
loved and in that period I was really
into modern American literature so I was
really into e el dr. o and there are
there are a few books that I just
absolutely loved and we talked about
that for a little while and then when we
turned to music I've played piano
classical piano since I was four and he
he and I talked about the the classical
musicians that I really loved and he
happened to be an English Lit major
along with being a physics major so he
he loved books as much as I did maybe
even more and then he was an opera nut
and so we had all these things that we
could talk about and two hours into that
conversation never having touched upon
technology he then basically said how
would you like to come work with me
and I was living out in Palo Alto at the
time this is an opportunity in Boston
and they remember not not even
hesitating knowing that I wanted to work
with this this person this human beings
sitting across the table from me I
jumped at that opportunity and it wasn't
it wasn't the fact that was in venture
capital but rather I really wanted the
chance to be working around someone like
Ted to interest me that that time let's
talk about that interview for a second
so that I think would strike some people
is a very unusual interviewing style do
you think in retrospect and maybe you
know that he had already decided you
were fully capable of doing the job
therefore it didn't have to check that
box and just wanted to make sure that he
could work with you and spend time with
you was it that he was using that
interview to sell you so that when he
made the offer you would say yes what do
you think was going through his mind
before during or after are I supposed
before and during that conversation you
know I think Ted is a very unique human
being in that when I used to have this
perception that networking was work in a
room and like you shake a lot of hands
and hold a lot of babies and you learn a
few names and you move on I learned from
Ted that networking is actually a deep
curiosity about the human being who's
sitting across the table from you so I
don't think he necessarily had that kind
of purpose in mind but that he was just
really interested in what I was
interested in and we happen to find
commonality and he was trying to
understand how my mind worked and what I
was interested in and I've taken that as
a real lesson because I love the way he
would network he he learned so much
about people in that process and and and
that's how he ministered to his
entrepreneurs he also
was capable of providing advice at the
right time because he really knew those
people and so so for me I felt like it
was a really unique interview it stood
out from all the interviews I've ever
had but I think she was learning more
about me than most other technical
interviews could have gotten to and then
you know his other partners I think ease
our harmony gave me sort of more of a
case study and could dive into that but
Ted always had a deep curiosity about
the human being and not necessarily just
the skills what else did you learn from
him or in that position in that in that
job I thought that Ted was also an
incredible first principles thinker so
this my second day of work at cr-v was
9/11 and so so it was you went from kind
of a bad economy to a horrible blackhole
economy and and so it was a really
terrible time for venture and they had
just raised this 1.4 billion dollar fund
and so that's I mean for venture that's
a huge amount of money and it's a huge
accomplishment to convince so many
investors to invest in your venture
capital firm at that amount but then Ted
took the time to actually start to do
analysis with me on how much capital had
gone into venture capital at that moment
and then the exits had stopped there are
no more IPOs no one was acquiring
companies the economy just came to a
screeching halt
and he decided along with the other
partners in this firm to give back most
of the money so they reduced their fund
from 1.2 billion dollars to 450 million
dollars and the reason why that's so
interesting and impressive is that the
way a venture capital firm makes money
way you have any salary or the operating
money that you have for the firm is a
direct percentage of the fund that you
raise and so by shrinking the size of
the fund you're shrinking the size of
the management fees that you get pretty
dramatically oh sure very dramatically I
mean for people who don't know I mean
you you hear very often it's not always
the case but in venture capital 2 and 22
and 20 and that means 2% management fee
based on the sort of assets under
management meaning that particular fund
and then 20% of the upside for people
who's right and so so they they decided
to give back those management fees and
and to me that was really really
impressive because you're you're facing
down a really terrible economy not only
are you shrinking the size of your fund
to reflect that you're also shrinking
the size of your management fees and
you're taking that blow and so so things
like that I learned I learned also you
know how to how to Shepherd companies
through that kind of difficult time and
how to be a true partner to an
entrepreneur and so you know I think it
was a really important lesson to learn
because I would argue most people
haven't seen real cycles people seem to
think 2008 was a real significant dip in
the economy but anyone who lives through
2001 knows that 2008 was a blip compared
to a real downturn and because we've had
a you know raging bull market for such a
long time yeah that that memory and that
knowledge of of having survived you know
2001 as a crisis period is something
that I hold with me really in my war
chest I I know how to get through that
kind of time period and I don't think a
lot of people do yeah it makes me think
of a lot of what I heard and Silicon
Valley still here I know before moving
to Austin which which makes me think of
I'm gonna paraphrase this but it's a
quote from Sir John Templeton I think it
is which is the
most expensive words and investing are
this time it's different
and it has been quite the bull run you
mentioned first principles thinking what
what are I want I want to tie that into
something you mentioned related to your
class tough choices for leaders what are
some of the toughest choices for leaders
I suppose in this context CEOs or
high-level execs cofounders of companies
what is what are some of the the
toughest decisions that nonetheless seem
to come up fairly commonly
I think the most difficult thing for a
start-up founder co-leader is that
especially when you're you see you
witness multiple phase changes in a
business and so if you imagine you're
going from absolutely nothing to
something that's what I call the zero to
one phase you're searching for product
market fit you're trying to find the
best customers you're trying to find
where your 10x advantage is truly valued
that's a very different business process
and truth seeking then when you're going
from one to X which is now that I know
what my value proposition is I'm going
to add to that but I'm also going to
pull on some of these growth levers the
the fundamental job of a VP of Marketing
who is in that zero to one phase changes
dramatically one to X it changes
dramatically for the the salesperson in
zero to one to one to X and you go
through this incredible Bermuda Triangle
where you have to navigate that change
and so so what I what I see challenging
for for startup founders is actually
being comfortable with your fundamental
job shifting from every three months you
would have a massive shift in what you
need to focus on and how you need to
develop and I think you know a company
is a multi-dimensional thing and and in
Silicon Valley we spend so much time
thinking about product and product
market fit that we forget that there's
this huge emphasis you might want to
place on the fact that a company is also
an organization a company is also a
category that you're building a company
is also a business model you know
company is also a team and so it's it's
it's the skill set actually to balance
all of those things
and knowing when you you you
fundamentally need to change out the
talent in your team
the knowing when you actually need to
let go of a product and knowing actually
to me this is probably the hardest piece
knowing the difference between a winning
strategy versus a strategy not to lose
could you elaborate on that please yeah
so to me a strategy not to lose is a lot
of different things it's to not to lose
to a competitor not to lose talent a
strategy not to lose out on revenue so
it's all these fears that you have of
captured ground or the fact that you
might have someone take over something
that you're you want to do a competitor
who's breathing down your neck versus a
strategy for winning is about where do
you double down on what do you do to
capture ground to be aggressive to play
offense and not defense to me that is a
huge difference between that strategy of
I'm gonna win in this market versus I'm
not going to lose and not losing often
invest in involves a lot of hedging and
when you feel that urge to hedge you
need to focus we need to be offensive
what what in what ways might that
hedging manifest what would be examples
you've seen or hypotheticals of the
symptoms of a defensive strategy in the
form of hedging great question it might
manifest itself in I am gonna go after
two very different customer segments one
is large enterprises the other small
medium businesses and the reason why
that's really hedging is you have two
completely different ways of selling to
those organizations and you're afraid to
pick
one because maybe you have some revenue
in both right but in that situation by
not choosing to focus on one group or
the other you're probably a
shortchanging your team because you
don't have a specialized team to go
after that opportunity your
shortchanging your business model
because you aren't pricing your product
correctly and your shortchanging the
opportunity because probably your
product isn't optimized for that
customer set your your customer services
and optimize for that product set and
your team is ultimately confused because
you're heading in two completely
different conditions and directions and
so I I believe that you know that that's
one of the most common ways that I see
people involved in a strategy of not
losing instead of we're here to win it
mm-hmm
yeah all of those things you mentioned
also contribute to lighting money on
fire right I mean that's that's split
focus the bonfire the bonfire of funding
or cash flow depending on where it comes
from the this is really important and
you know this but I want to underscore
it for people listening and give a few
other examples that might be worth
people might enjoy exploring so this
winning versus not losing distinction
seems really subtle but you can get an
in to to feel for it in a few different
ways one is there's actually a I think
it's a three-part miniseries podcast
called the making of Oprah and it talks
about the rise of Oprah I know this
seems like an odd segue Oprah impresses
the hell out of me in a million
different ways and after you listen to
this you'll understand exactly why
that's the case but she would constantly
tell her team many of whom wanted to
respond to say Donahue who was the
800-pound gorilla at the time like we
need to race our own race in the sense
that if you're on a thoroughbred horse
and you're in a race you need to focus
on your race you can't be looking side
to side
at the the competitors the racers next
to you get yourself into a lot of
trouble or you get really injured and
the second is if people want to Google
Dan Gable on aggression there's a short
video I put on my blog that hits this
point exactly and I'm giving examples
from different disciplines because I it
is cross-disciplinary it's not just
investing in startups Dan Gable is the
most legendary wrestling coach certainly
over the last I would say a hundred
years in the United States also won a
gold medal in the 1972 Munich Olympics
without having a single point scoring on
him that just does not happen and this
video will show you a lecture that he's
giving one of his athletes after his
athlete tied and he said you lost to him
twice before you just didn't want to
lose he said you never win that way
you got a tie and that's that's exactly
why you got a tie and the differences is
just so powerful and it's it's worth I
just thought taking a second to to
underscore it because I think it's it's
really a critical distinction that you
brought up it's sort of like I think
about it I love to ski and I had this
instructor once I was complaining about
going through powder and I was I was
saying how it really hurt my my thighs
he was like my thighs are burning and he
looks at me he said it's because you're
not leaning forward and and like the
minute you lean forward suddenly you're
just gliding and it's scary in that
moment when you lean forward because you
feel like you're gonna fall and yet it
gives you so much more control and it
gives you so much it's so much less
effort counter-intuitively
and that to me is like the perfect
example of like you have to actually
have a little bit of aggressiveness in
order to have the win I think you are
are well-suited in that respect how did
how did you meet the
how did you meet the man who so famously
tries to trick not trick that sounds too
strong who so commonly will say
something like well I'm just a southern
boy maybe you could slow down and
explain that one more time which by the
way if you ever hear anything like that
like really stop and pay attention
because you're you are about to be
tricked or misdirected I've actually
borrowed that and I use that for long
long island a little but you know I'm
just a slow Long Island but I take a
second maybe you can explain that to me
again how did you meet Mike maples jr.
yes this actually happened in one of the
classes that I was teaching at Stanford
he was he was one of the mentors for a
bunch of teams so we had all these teams
who were creating business plans for for
their own version of a startup company
and we had incredible mentors to each of
these teams we had I think someone who
was the former CEO of Verisign we had I
think Diane green might have been a
mentor to one of the teams Diane Greene
is for those who know Diane green is now
the head of Google cloud she was also
the CEO of VMware big deal a big big
deal so big deal big deal and what we
what we did was we would team up some of
these entrepreneurs or people in Silicon
Valley with a student team and Mike was
one of them and for for people who know
Mike he's just this charming guy boy
from Oklahoma
he calls himself sometimes a washed-up
Enterprise VC and or washed-up
Enterprise entrepreneur but he's not and
so he came to our class and he was
mentoring this team but he was actually
being too nice and so this was having
like all sorts of weird issues they were
fighting and they came to my office
hours and one of them started to cry and
[Music]
spotting a theme here within proximity
of right I did not make this team member
so I was just kind of I was really I was
kind of mad at Mike because part of the
the role of the mentor is to help
Shepherd them through these tough points
and he was just kind of checked out on
that front and and I emailed him he said
oh yeah like team's doing great and I
said wow I kind of beg to differ
they were just in my office and one of
them started to cry and they're fighting
and right now if they don't pull it
together they're really gonna fail the
class and he just wrote me this message
that said well I think they're gonna get
an A+ and so it was so far not tracking
and so we just sort of had this friendly
banter and actually the team does turn
it around and they ended up getting an
a-plus in the class and intervenor did
he just throw some turtle shells on a
desk and like divine his way to that
outcome I'm not really sure but I
actually take full credit for the
turnaround because had I not pointed it
out to Mike then the team would have
just imploded and and so so based on
that interaction you know a few years
later I was starting to get to a point
in my PhD where I was thinking of
starting my own company and I had
started my PhD in computer security
exactly because I knew that it didn't
matter when I graduated there would be a
computer security problem out there and
I would be I wouldn't be at risk of
market timing and it was sort of a
perfect opportunity because just as I
was going through my research it was
from 2003 to 2007 at this point we had
transformed from this world of where
security used to be a bunch of vandalism
problems too now there were companies
involved and like real money was being
involved and so real crime was being
created here and then towards the end
there was really like nation-state
warfare starting to happen and so my my
research was really in risk management
computer security and I knew that this
was becoming a huge issue and so I
started to think I'm gonna make a
company and so at that moment I turned
to you some of my advisers and my
advisors were nice enough to say hey if
you're thinking about starting company
you've been in the ivory towers for
literally four years so you should get
out of the classroom and go check out
some angel investors and then Mike was
one of the first people I turned to and
I asked him if I could see his deal flow
and he was nice enough to say sure why
don't you just come in and take a look
at my deal flow on Wednesdays and so we
would sit next to each other and look at
companies and deal flow means the the
sort of top of the funnel companies that
he's considering potentially investing
in right they would come in and pitch
for between 30 minutes in an hour and
then at the end of that I I think it was
you know March of 2008 he calls me as
I'm actually going up to Tahoe to ski he
calls me to say hey and I have this
great idea I just raised my first fund
it's thirty five million dollars and I
think that you should drop out of your
ph.d program and join me and it's not
the venture-backed startup that you've
been thinking about but it's now a
backed venture startup let's go oh I
like that that's really good now was
that an immediate yes or is it oh let me
sleep on it I actually thought he was
crazy because first of all you know I
was literally again I was in nobody I'm
a PhD candidate I don't even have my
degree at Stanford so there's like all
these Business School students there's
great you know angel investors milling
around why the major question was like
why does this guy think that I would
actually be a good investor
then the the second piece was there
weren't a ton of venture capital firms
that were being started up so even when
I went back to people who were my
mentors some of them said why would you
go to a no-name VC why won't you go and
be an associate at you know kleiner
perkins or Excel or you know Sequoia
yeah and I don't really have a good
answer John just to set the stage for
folks who don't know maybe the recent
history in Silicon Valley at the time
that Mike had proposed this to you sort
of micro-cap venture capital was barely
a thing right I mean it's it's there
there are a lot of funds of all sorts of
different sizes now but at the time this
was very unusual yeah and so it was you
know at this point in when we get to
2018 there's probably you know 30 funds
being pitched a week to a limited
partner who invests into these venture
capital firms but back then there was
very very few and so it was really a
question of is this the smart thing to
do and I think this is sort of where you
know when you turn to an entrepreneur
this is the feeling that they get what I
what I sensed was there was actually a
major change afoot all of the students
around me at Stanford didn't need five
million dollars to start a company and
that's what venture capital was offering
to startups at that point they would say
I will buy 50 percent of your company
for five million dollars right it was
predicated on the entry costs being very
high in summers very very high and like
at that point you know we suddenly have
open source software we really have
what's starting to look like cloud
computing we have all the shared
resources so even though I was helping
to run servers in the closet at my grad
school in our lab that was starting to
become something that we didn't need
there was actually you know services
that you can use where you could rent
services and so
to me there was a dramatic change that
was happening and so you had to change
the financing environment and so I felt
like I could see something that everyone
else didn't see that Mike was also
seeing and he used to say five hundred
thousand is the new five million and and
then the second piece for me was this
guy Mike maples had a skill set I had
never seen before I made maybe in like
one or two other people in my entire
lifetime but he was this incredible
marketer and I used to believe you
either built things or you sold things
everything else just seemed like an
extraneous skill set to have but Mike
was incredible at storytelling and
positioning and and and strategy like
real strategy for how do you create a
new category and how do you build that
category and how do you create the king
of that category and as an engineer I
hadn't thought about what you do after
you build the product and so this magic
of category creation to me was something
that almost felt like magic and so I
looked at Mike and I thought I really
need to learn from this person and and
not only is it a great skill set that
I'm learning from he is also genuinely
one of the best human beings that that
I've ever encountered and so it was just
her this magical combination of someone
whose values really aligned with me and
how I wanted to build a firm and the
things that I wanted to do with that and
how I wanted to treat entrepreneurs and
in a person who was a mad genius and so
that combination to me was irresistible
and so a couple months into it I said
sign me up a couple of months all right
so question number one just for for
people who are wondering and I know a
lot of people you seem very good at
avoiding the sunk cost fallacy and this
is so so so key this cognitive bias
I when you were looking at the quitting
of the ph.d program did you I don't know
how it works at Stanford but realize you
kind of you didn't have to quit I did
not quit so so that first year and a
half of my life within at floodgate was
crazy because at that point I joined
floodgate and I have an 18 month old
child my daughter Abby and then I you
know I think it was four or five months
into it I am pregnant with my second
child I've promised my mother as any
good Asian daughter would that I will
finish this PhD if it's the last thing I
do so I'm waking up at like 4 o'clock in
the morning doing research until you
know seven when she wait my daughter
wakes up then taking her to daycare and
then working from like 8:30 to 6:30 that
floodgate and then coming back doing
dinner and then working on my PhD again
rinse and repeat and then I got pregnant
with my second child a few months into
that and then decided I was going to
defend my PhD they set the date for six
weeks after I gave birth to my son and
so you know I I not only did my first
set of investments but also had gave
birth to a child cared for another one
and managed to stay married and finish
this PhD all between 2008 and 2009 and
so you know to me like that's like the
most creative and probably productive
period of my life ever and probably will
be but but also showed me that I can
actually do a lot of things that
everyone around me was like why would
you do all of those things at the same
time how does how does this going to
seem like a non-sequitur kind of is but
how does how does your mom say your name
because Ann is sort of an unusual first
name
oh no my first name my first name is a
bad call
nickel yeah mako-chan
deco chance the boy in there I barely
that's another word everybody should
look up and learn s you GOI Sequoia and
that just means sort of awesome
impressive a whole all sort of things
because I can barely manage to brush my
teeth and shower on a daily basis and
yet you're doing all these things
simultaneously
I have to pause at this point just to
try to fill out the the some of the the
colors of who they quote John Americo is
what have you struggled with like have
you had any dark really it doesn't have
to be dark but difficult times dark
times that you could tell us about and
where you were you really struggled or
is that not part of your sort of lexicon
no I think we all have struggles right
so I think even in this moment of like
the PhD and caring for my kids and
caring for myself and my husband my
family and all and trying to do a good
job at work like things slip right and
and I I struggle with this still today
and this is where the darkness comes in
is like am i doing anything well like am
I good mother am I you know I didn't I
wasn't today my six-year-old is on a
field trip and he asked me why is it
that you never get to come on a field
trip like those are all these moments
where you wonder like am i failing at
being a parent or you know I I I'm not
able to get to the dishes and my I had a
moment where my my front door neighbor
is actually a Japanese woman a nosy
Japanese woman and she went up to she
went up to my mother and she said you
know your family is so strange I always
see the husband doing the dishes but
never the wife
the wife that is the most nosy Japanese
neighbor thing to say ever like I spent
two days like in that in that front
window doing dishes and at some point I
was like ah screw this but it's like oh
no it is this constant battle of how do
I figure out what my priority is so that
I have like minimum viable you know
progress on some fronts and then the
thing that really matters I'm going to
make massive progress on and so so that
that's where the darkness creeps in I
think you know for me my my really
looser moments have been things like you
know early on I just described to you
early how there were tests that always
said like I wasn't that smart there were
you know lots of examples where I wasn't
good at a lot of different things that
other people found very normal like I
was horrible at standardized tests only
until I got to like senior year junior
year in high school did I finally figure
it out like there's so many places where
so many people said distinctly average
maybe not even that smart and and I
think for me it's been learning to tune
out the naysayers and knowing that there
are certainly a lot of things I'm not
going to be good at but there are things
that I can actually be great at a really
good example that actually is my PhD I
remember when I got to my PhD at
Stanford and I'm starting first of all
like I took a math class and there were
high school or college freshmen in this
class and it felt like the math teacher
was speaking Greek and the freshmen are
flying through this material because
they're like little kid geniuses and I
remember thinking to myself well clearly
I should not be getting a PhD in math
and thank goodness this is
in operations research then I had this
second experience where the professor a
new professor came in across the hall
from me his name is Ramesh Johari and he
was my age because I'd taken five years
off to start my PhD he was literally my
age and he was incredible he could
remember things about different papers
and theorems and how they were proved
from like years past compare and
contrast them he just knew things that I
struggled to remember and I remember
looking at him and being in one of his
seminars and thinking to myself that is
world class as an academic and I'm I'm
okay at it but I would have moments
where I was like I'm I'm actually not
even good at it and then I would go to a
conference and like when you when you
compare yourself against the world of
PhD students and obvious then you start
to develop a little bit more confidence
then you go back to Stanford and you see
what world-class is and and I was
thinking to myself this isn't the path
and and there's a there's a place where
I actually can use the skill sets that I
do have where I can be really good at
the things that I'm doing and so if you
if if I if I I'm sitting here saying you
know I was always good at everything
that I did it's just not true there are
so many moments where I realized it's
like being a doctor I said I would not
be good at being a doctor I would not be
great at being an academic I would not
be great at a lot of different things
just knowing and having the
self-awareness of where I would double
down is I think what I was good at and
so so it makes the this emergent life
where I was going from one track to
another I was gonna be a doctor and then
I went to McKinsey and then I went to VC
and then I went to get a PhD and then I
went back to VC this is all
self-discovery rather than a stated path
that I had career plan for a long time
well it strikes me also that and maybe
I'm trying to create a narrative where
there isn't one or a connection but it
seems reasonable that Mike's superpower
or one of his abilities to help create
categories and sort of mint Kings within
a given category is actually a different
species of something that you're also
good at which is kind of a Jack Welch
Ian in a sense and that is you're
looking at the different paths you could
take and if you can't be say number one
or number two in that thing
it just gets rolled out and you're
asking this world-class question over
and over again and one way is to find
something where you can dominate and
really be world-class and the other is
to create an entirely new category in a
sense yes so it seems like you and Mike
are very complementary in that way and
have that shared programming I've heard
people describe you as an investor when
your strengths is being technical which
I suppose seems self-evident given your
background but how would your colleagues
how would how would Mike let's say
describe your if I asked him what what
are ants superpowers is an investor
there are a lot of investors out there
what is what what is ends superpower set
of superpowers what would you say I
think for me the superpowers I have are
a few folds so one is because of the the
technical capabilities that I have when
someone is describing particularly
anything that has to do with math and
luckily for me right now
math is having this incredible
resurgence in artificial intelligence
and in cryptocurrency I I can get that
piece I can get that piece better than I
would say probably 99% of the investors
out there and so if I get a math paper
that's something that I love to dig into
and that technical insight is something
that I think I'm better at than most
other investors out there and then from
there I can also start to piece together
what that company will look like around
that technology and so it's not just I'm
looking for great R&D projects but ones
that are ripe to be Big D and little R
and and I think that's a superpower
especially at the very early stage so
one of the companies that I invested in
back in 2010 a Yas T they've gone over a
hundred million dollars in financing at
this point and I found them when they
were they didn't even have a business
plan they had four math papers that they
sent to me and and so to me that that's
something that I I double down on and
it's a it's a part of the types of
investments that I like to do that's
very different from you know the task
rabbits refinery29 and lift that I've
done in the past as well I think the
other superpower that is a little bit
less evident is more evident as I'm
working with people is I feel like I
have a pretty good sixth sense about the
people dynamics within an organization
so I can tell when there's actually
infighting happening I can sense when
executive is starting to disengage and
those are things that that I work on
with a lot of the CEOs that I work with
and then the last piece that I think I
really love to engage in is the
fundamental data behind the business and
so I love looking at the cohort analysis
and really engaging on data because
that's that's a piece of the puzzle that
I feel like I'm also good at encoding
unencoded mm-hmm
what are you looking for now and what
are funder losers we mentioned hunting
thunderlizards earlier and I promised I
would come back to it so maybe we define
that first and perhaps you could tell us
what you're looking for at the moment
yeah so so a thunder lizard is inspired
by Godzilla it's a term that Mike my
partner used to always tell this story
which is that we are inspired by
entrepreneurs who are like Godzilla and
so what is Godzilla like he's born from
radioactive atomic eggs so the DNA of
that entrepreneur is already
fundamentally different and then he
swims across the Pacific Ocean and
depending on if you're Mike or me he
lands in either the Bay Area or Tokyo
and starts to wreak havoc and eats
trains and automobiles and buildings and
then proceeds to crush that that
industry and creates disruption and then
build something out of that and and so
you know that that idea of disruption is
something that that I always liked that
imagery of like the journey across the
Pacific Ocean born from something
fundamentally different and then really
starting to turn things over and so so
when we say okay what are we looking for
right now in terms of where do we think
the new thunderlizards will exist
there's sort of two different areas it
comes back to the math that that I'm
really interested in one is I do think
that artificial intelligence is about to
disrupt a lot of different types of
enterprise software I think that
enterprise software still sucks and if
we're going to be able to really
transform the way a business is actually
operated we have to take these the
software that just basically records
data and spits it back out to you into
something that's actually more
intelligent that tells you something
that you didn't know that gives you
superpowers and and I think that we're
going to see more and more
of that in the industry and so as an
example like baseline examples why do we
spend millions of dollars on Oracle or
NetSuite when the the CFO still has to
make a budget for next year why doesn't
that financial planning just
automatically automagically generate
itself based on all the history that it
knows plus all the data from the
external world so I think things like
that we're gonna start to see happen
more and more I also think you know
fundamentally the scientific method may
also be dead like we list used to have
the scientific method was developed in a
time where we didn't have enough data
and data was actually the fundamental
bottleneck in scientific research well
that's just not the case anymore
and so why is it that we form a
hypothesis then look at the data and
then come to a conclusion we should have
all the data then have a an analysis
that that leads us to a hypothesis or a
belief system that we fundamentally test
further so I think these massive changes
are coming and and you see it even in in
cryptocurrency
there's also really philosophical
interesting debates happening around
well you have this massive pull toward
centralization whether it's in AI and ml
where you have to have all that data in
one place in order to really train ml be
a machine learning machine learning or
in cloud computing you're also putting
it up into the data into more in data
centers in cryptocurrency we believe
that there's going to be more
decentralized software and so how do you
reconcile those two types of systems I
think there's lots of really interesting
themes that are just at the start of
being discovered I'm really excited
about what what's going to happen with
autonomous vehicles and the technology
that is going to be required to make
that a reality and so all of those areas
I think are
just fascinating and so it feels like a
period of real intellectual abundance
and that we're headed into a period of
real great creative energy and a time
where a lot of your philosophical
training and reading will be put into
practice and the real [ __ ] hold right
where we have yeah if you look at the
people can look up the trolly scenario
or it's typically thought of as a
thought exercise but if you're
programming not take us to off on a
tangent but if you're programming for
autonomous vehicles and there's some
type of act of god a hailstorm a huge
boulder falls in the middle of the
street and the car has to swerve left
and hit two school kids or swerve right
and hit you know five geriatrics you
know how does it make the decision right
what is the logic embedded into that
machine it's it's really it takes a lot
of these philosophy 101 thought
exercises and it translates them very
directly into the real world with real
consequences it is it is a fascinating
time and how much it's also like how
much do you want to know right so deep
learning it's actually very difficult to
know what's happened inside of this
black box and and so there's more of a
demand for let's know what's actually
happening this inside of this black box
especially if lives are risk or if
billions of dollars are at risk and we
need to be able to audit these these
algorithms I think there's really real
interest in new technologies now that we
can actually audit and know what's going
on inside the box so that you know if
the the trolly example happens we
actually know how the machines will make
their decisions and so I think there's a
lot of work to be done a lot of
opportunity but also a lot of thought
that needs to go into how we want to
regulate all of this tricky tricky
tricky yeah yeah well it's gonna be
going to be exciting very very
interested to see how all these things
coalesce right also you're looking at
these gigantic companies Facebook's
Google's the fangs right that are more
and more so converging onto the same
territory to see how that resolves if it
does in some fashion is is also really
really exciting to me or how something
like Y Combinator just to do a little
bit of insight baseball can say we are
interested in this type of company or
this particular aspect of engineering or
fill in the blank and it's kind of steer
the attention of thousands or tens of
thousands of would-be entrepreneurs into
a particular sector right or type of
project is also just really interesting
to think about from the the
ramifications five years down the line
right but anyway maybe we like I think
we have so many incredible societal
problems that need to be solved and I
believe that the private sector is most
capable of solving these problems right
whether its energy or health or you know
the fact that we have so much trash how
do we solve that how do we get clean
water to people it's not just about the
next social network and how do we
deliver better advertising to people but
you know the the beauty of of this type
of entrepreneurship is that there are
huge societal problems that still need
to be solved that I think you know is is
a really exciting opportunity also to
build great businesses around and so I
think that's that's also what gets me up
in the morning and makes me believe that
that what we're doing is important work
yeah it is important work I don't think
that sort of collective interest and
self-interest have to be misaligned
right they're not mutually exclusive you
can you can solve and there's a long
history of solving public problems with
private sector
technologies and companies and let me
just ask I knew we we've gone a little
bit longer than expected which I should
have expected they ask you there's a few
more questions and then moles wrap-up
with where people can find you and learn
more about what you're up to besides
getting to yes are there any books that
you've given a lot as gifts or reread a
lot yourself um oh gosh for me you know
right now there is there's a couple
books that I think are are super
interesting so my mentor Ted dentro
Smith just wrote a book called what
school could be and this goes back to
sort of education as a critical societal
question how do we fix education and
what he did was he went on a 50-state
tour to look at schools and discover
that the answers are actually already
there and our incredible school teachers
throughout our country are already
finding solutions to teaching our kids
the most important skills they need to
have and I think reading that book has
not only given me hope but also a desire
to see real change in the public school
education system but I think that's a
really important problem for all of us
to actually engage in and so that's one
book that I would really push on to
other people the other one that is
completely on the opposite end of the
spectrum but it is a fiction book it is
by Khaled Hosseini who also wrote Kite
Runner hmm
he wrote this book called a Thousand
Splendid Suns and probably one of the
most beautiful books that I've read in a
long time in terms of fiction writing
and I would encourage people to read it
because gives you a sense of
Afghanistan's incredible history and the
role women have played within that his
and I I just loved that book because it
just was eye-opening to me in a very
different way so two very different
types of books none of them like
straightforward business books but ones
that I think are meaningful for our
society to read today what school could
be in 1,000 splendid sons
yeah is there any purchase of $100 or
less it's kind of arbitrary right but
just not a Bugatti or something that is
most positively impacted your life or
positively impacted your life in recent
memory $100 or less yeah it could be I
mean look if it's if it's like a
foldable kayak that you got for 400
that's fine too but it could be could be
anything could be $2.00 could be free it
could be any recent addition to your
life it's actually a foldable chair so I
go to my daughter's soccer tournaments a
lot and there's this incredible foldable
chair I don't know what it's called you
can get in on Amazon but it has this
flip-over sunshade that goes over your
head and for any parent who has been at
a swim tournament or anything this is
life-changing because often times I'm
just baking in the hot Sun and you can
be anywhere and you have your own
personal tent that like folds over your
head it's been it's like saved me on
multiple weekends my husband bought two
of them I love it can you send me a link
to that and I'll put it in the show
notes if yes if you can track it down so
for people wondering I'll put that in
the show notes at Tim Dunn blog forward
slash podcast and you can you can find
this miraculous foldable chair if you
could have a giant billboard anywhere
with anything on it so metaphorically
speaking getting a a word a quote a
message a question anything out to
millions or billions of people can't be
an advertisement what might you put on
that billboard Wow
hmm I wonder if it's like not losing
does not equal winning sort of one of my
one of my themes
these days I like that yeah and I think
actually finding your world-class life
is probably the other one that I would
think about will give you find your work
world-class life and I think the reason
for that is to me everyone is capable of
that and I think oftentimes we forget it
and and for every person it's different
that's the beauty of humanity so what do
the characters for vehicle mean oh my
gosh so it means it's a small round Bell
mm-hmm and the reason for my parents
naming me that was they were originally
gonna name me something more like you
know really beautiful child or you know
genius child and my mom my mom took one
look at me when I was born she's like no
none of those she said your face was so
perfectly round when you were born it
reminds me of this like perfectly round
Bell mom like all these other friends
that I have especially Chinese friends
they're like super intelligent like
world class dominating dictator for life
CEO child you know and I'm like small
Bell child nico-chan
and where can people find you online say
hello learn more about what you were up
to
I think professionally the best place is
to see my Twitter which is an ax maniac
a n n IMA and IA c mm-hmm or on
instagram it's a mi you are a you'll see
more of my life there a muta yes three
bays so what that means
muta something like that major
it's a twitter twitter and a maniac
Instagram a muta mi you are a and best
website floodgate its floodgate comm
plug it calm Y floodgate what is a
floodgate why is it called a floodgate
yeah yeah cuz we think we're at the
forefront of like the the headwaters of
innovation and so and and and it sounded
I don't know kind of big and audacious
good enough reason audacious audacious
yes
audacious aggressive but still the
mother of dragons there is a nurturing
mother like there is den mother quality
to Annie you're like a mama bear you
know oh I'm very protective but also I'm
gonna push my kids and people around me
to be the best they can be just don't
get him don't get him between the mother
and the cub good guide lion and I won't
say for anybody who's wondering what
would it be like to just go sort of
mano-a-mano with and I would say you
know you're one of the few people I
would put Sam Harris in this category
where if you if you are willing to
engage in like a public debate with
either of you you just have to make sure
that you have practice defending against
having your face ripped off and like the
most logical complimentary way possible
I'm just very impressed by you and and
I've really wanted to have you on the
show for a long time and I'm paying you
know that you were willing to carve out
a few hours to spend chatting and it's
always fun chatting we still have Tim
you've been there from the very GetGo
you were you were the person behind my
very first investment in TaskRabbit so I
have a lot to thank you for as well
well the the adventure shall continue
and I will certainly am NOT as
involved as I used to be in the tech
scene but I'll be cheering from the
sidelines so anything else that you'd
like to say or suggest or mention any
parting words before we wrap up now I
hope that your audience enjoyed this and
if they got anything out of it that they
if they want to contact me I'm always
open to more conversations and I hope
that some of my story shows that even if
people tell you you can't do something
that that you can you can indeed just
gonna spend the summer reading up on
those 12 topics that's right you can't
always out talent everyone but if you
out prepare them you might as well have
out talented them maybe the billboard
sign is effort matters it does well and
thank you so much again this is this has
been such a treat and and a gift and I
look forward to hearing what people have
to say on the on the interwebs and
perhaps we'll do a round two in person
during during one of what what's the
name of the was it the Tim Ferriss why
an hour what was this they call it
Ferriss time which was the little wine
per teeth just sue that the edges that
describe that describe he just grabs a
glass he's like I think it's fair a sour
I'll take it I will take it and and I
will talk to you soon and see you soon I
hope and yes to everybody listening you
can find links to everything we
discussed the books the fold-out chair
and much more getting to yes and so on
in the show notes as you can with all
episodes if Tim top log forward slash
podcast and until next time thank you
for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell that out and just drop in with
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoyed this episode is brought to you
by LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as
while WordPress the developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NBA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour because Leo zoom
isn't a law firm so they won't be
running the clock up and spinning
circles just to raise your bill instead
they just ask you to pay one low upfront
price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get Alucard style so visit
legalzoom.com and check out their
business section for all their services
and if you want special savings
that's the terminology in the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lowercase I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
Tim this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com or everything every day my
site Tim that blog is built on it
the websites form books with tools of
titans tribe of mentors all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg when my close friends has
appeared on this show many times
just search Matt Mullenweg tequila
Ferriss or quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog business site or both you
can make a really big impact right out
of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by The New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 538 TechCrunch Ted CNN and
time just to name a handful and one of
my friends at Google children nameless
has told his head wordpress.com offers
these best out-of-the-box
SEO imaginable and put it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30 percent of
the Internet is run on board best you do
not need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part where best
calm guide you through the entire
experience they have hundreds of designs
and templates that you use and easy to
get started there's no need to worry
about security upgrades posting any of
that now for 24/7 support and they're
very very responsive you questions they
go right back to you and this allows you
to create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period and
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out do
get started today learn more with a 15%
discount off any new plan go to
wordpress.com poet slash tim create your
website and find the plan is right for
you so learn more take a look
wordpress.com 4/10 50% off a brand-new
check it out
you